welcome everyone this is part two in our
series on grounded language
understanding our task for this unit is
essentially a natural language
generation task and i've called those
speakers the ideas that speakers go from
the world that is some non-linguistic
thing that they're trying to communicate
about into language those are really the
central agents that we'll be exploring
to ground all this we're going to have a
simple task i'm going to start with the
most basic version of the task that will
ultimately tackle in our assignment and
bake off and that is color reference
so these are examples taken from a
corpus that was originally correct
collected by randall monroe of xkcd fame
and processed into an nlp task by
mcmahon in stone 2015. and it's a simple
formulation in that the state of the
world we want to communicate about is a
color patch
and the task is simply to produce
descriptions of those color patches and
i've given some examples here and you
can see that they range from simple one
word descriptions uh all the way up to
things that are kind of complicated both
cognitively and linguistically and i
think point to the idea that even though
this is a simple and constrained domain
it's a pretty cognitively and
linguistically interesting one
so our speakers uh at least our baseline
speakers are standard versions of
encoder decoder models we're going to
have for this initial formulation a very
simple encoder the task of the encoder
is simply to take a color representation
which is going to be a list of floats
embed it in some embedding space and
then learn some hidden representation
for that color and that's all that needs
to happen so it's just one step
the decoder is where the speaking part
happens so the initial token produced by
the decoder by the speaker is always the
start token which is looked up in an
embedding space
and then we get our first decoder hidden
state which is created from the color
representation as the initial hidden
state in the sequence we're going to
build together with an embedding and
both of those have weight
transformations and it's an additive
combination of them that delivers this
value h1 here
then we use some softmax parameters to
make a prediction about the next token
here we've predicted dark
and we get our error signal by comparing
that prediction with the actual token
that occurred in our training data in
this case it was the word light so since
we've made a wrong prediction we're
going to get
a substantive error signal that will
then we hope update the weight
parameters throughout this model in a
way that leads them to produce better
generations the next time
in a little more detail just as a
reminder so we have an embedding for
that start token indeed for all tokens
the hidden state is derived from the
embedding via a weight transformation
and the color representation which is
state h0 and the recurrence that we're
building and that too has a
transformation applied to it to travel
through the hidden layer
that gives us the state h1 and then we
have softmax parameters on top of that
h1 that make a prediction
uh the prediction that they make is a
prediction over the entire vocabulary
and the probability of the actual token
gives us our error signal so the
probability of light is the error signal
that we'll use here to update the model
parameters
and then we begin with the next time
step i've called this teacher forcing
because in the standard mode which is
the teacher forcing mode even though we
predicted dark at time step one we're
going to have as our second token the
seek the the token light
which is the actual token in the
underlying training data when we proceed
as though we did not make a mistake so
again we do an embedding lookup we get
our second hidden state for the decoder
as a combination of the embedding x37
and the previous hidden state and we
make another prediction and in this case
our prediction is blue and that's the
actual token and life is good for a
little bit and then we proceed with the
third time step
the actual token is blue
h3
and we predict green and in this case we
should have predict the stop token which
would cause us to stop processing the
sequence we're just going to get an
error signal as we standardly would and
propagate that back down through the
model in hopes that the next time when
we want to stop we'll actually produce
this stop token that i've given up here
at prediction time of course the
sequence is not given that doesn't
change the encoder because the color
representation is part of the model
inputs but then we have to decode and
just describe without any feedback so we
proceed as we did before and we predict
dark here and then dark has to become
the token at the next time step because
we don't know what the ground truth is
and we proceed as before and say blue
and then that becomes the third time
step and with luck there in that third
position we predict the stop token and
the decoding process is completed
that is the fundamental model
even though it's simple it admits of
many interesting modifications let me
just mention a few of them
first the encoder and the decoder of
course could have many more hidden
layers mine just had one but they could
be very deep networks we would expect
that the layer counts for the encoder
and the decoder and match so that you
have this even handoff from encoder to
decoder across all the hidden layers but
even that's not a hard constraint i can
imagine that some cooling or copying
could accommodate different numbers of
layers in these two components
it's very common at present for
researchers to tie the embedding and
classifier parameters right the
embedding gives us a representation for
every vocabulary item and the transpose
of that can serve as the set of
parameters for our softmax classifier
when we predict tokens
and tying those weights seems to be very
productive in terms of optimization
effectiveness so you might consider that
and finally during training we might
drop that teacher forcing assumption
which would mean that in a small
percentage of cases we would allow the
model to just proceed as though its
predicted token was the correct token
for the next time step even if that was
a faulty assumption obvious on the idea
that that might help the model explore a
wider range of the space and inject its
um generations with some helpful
diversity
and then there's one other modification
that i want to mention because you'll
see this as part of the homework and the
system that you're developing so we
found that in monroidal 2016 it was
helpful to kind of remind the decoder at
each one of its time steps about what it
was trying to describe so in more detail
we had hsv color representations as our
inputs we did a fourier transform to get
an embedding and that was processed into
a hidden state and then during decoding
we appended to each one of the
embeddings the fourier transformation
representation of the color as a kind of
informal reminder at each time step
about what the input was actually like
on the assumption that for long
sequences when we get all the way down
to the end the model might have a hazy
memory of what it's trying to describe
and this functions as a kind of reminder
at that point
and that proved to be very effective and
i'll encourage you to explore that in
the homework
and then i hope you can see that even
though this task formulation is simple
it's an instance of a wide range of
tasks that we might explore under the
heading of grounding after all for
grounding in this sense we just need
some non-linguistic representation
coming in and the ideas that will
generate language in response to that
input
so image capturing is an instance of
this
scene description of course is another
instance visual question answering is a
slight modification where the input is
not just an image but also a question
text and the idea is that you want to
produce an answer to that question
relative to the image input
and then instruction giving would be a
more general form where the input is
some kind of state description and the
idea is that we want to offer a
complicated instruction on that basis
and i think we can think of many others
that would fit into this mold and
benefit not only from the encoder
decoder architecture but also from
conceptualization explicitly
as grounded natural language generation
tasks
you